how do you come up with your recipes
you're saying they're under 30 minutes
the recipes - you write the script for
my husband writes music I write food you
know I love to cook in my head I love to
daydream and is it just cooking i
furniture now - I love I draw for the
kitchen
I drew my oval pots and pans on a
cocktail napkin and gave it to my
husband to take to the food show and
said go find these people I like the way
they make their pots and show them my
shapes see if they'll take a meeting
right I love to everything with a pen
and paper when I was a little girl the
most important thing to me was my
notebook and everything I drew had a
pouch and my mother said why do you only
draw girls and I said what do you mean
well the fish the giraffes all the
people they're all carrying purses
purses that's where they keep their
notebook so for me everything starts in
notebooks I have 25 years of notebooks
of everything I've ever cooked in my
home and every idea I ever had for
furniture or you know I always that
business my house the furniture business
going for me pretty good I'm up to my
ninth collection I've only been doing a
couple years so it's amazing I love it
do you remember your first time walking
into the studio and into this studio
this was many years into our shop yeah
we only came to this studio a few years
ago and I begged begged begged my
partners for this space I gave back some
of my own salary to cover the cost
because it was expensive I fell in love
with this studio I wanted it it's like I
was just stupid you know how when two
partners go looking for a property
you're supposed to not say how cool you
think it is until after you go straights
price I I'm really good at poker I'm
crap at real estate like the second I
saw this place someone that's fine and
I'm very very happy here and it was
worth it you know I mean I think I've
never had money be a motivator to me
yeah
it just isn't why I go to work I want
it's more important to me to have an
environment I'm comfortable in and that
I I think it brings out the best in me
and I absolutely have to be in a
building where animals and children are
loud I mean yeah there was a woman that
worked here for years she used to bring
her cat with her I bring my pitbull you
know they get a little hurt a little
friend that she's known since they were
both puppies penny you know comes here
and it's an environment where we're all
happy to spend as long as it takes to
get our job done because it doesn't feel
like work it just feels like we're all
know what a big house party this
overcome often now Oprah
comes as often as she can yeah hosted
our 2,000th episode and she had come a
couple months before that and she always
sends little videos and Gayle comes very
frequently I can't I have yeah we on the
Oprah show several times that's how I
got this gig that's how Oprah became a
part of our family here I cook for over
many times on your show I'm and of
course she's had the food here when she
comes here so yes I've had she ever
given you a piece of advice that you
keep times I mean please everything from
working out does have to be your best
workout just do something just move
you'll feel better mentally and it's
true the first time I did her show I was
a train wreck I felt so nervous and I
thought I was talking gibberish
whoo and she went to commercial break
and she leaned in and she's like he's
got it just take a breath you know like
oh wait makes everything okay she's like
the spoonful of sugar to me you know I
mean she's like a Mary Poppins got
everything and I don't know how she does
it but she's just you're just calm and
happy when you're around her she's one
of those peeps so what's next for you I
don't know I don't plan you don't what I
don't plan I love to work and then
whatever happens is what happens I just
like getting out of bed and having
projects you know and I always have to
have a notebook even in bed I have to
have a notebook next to the bed because
ideas come to me all the time and I just
scribble them down that doesn't mean
every one of them excellent